it's hard to promote without yeah being
able to be specific yeah I know it's my
fondest hope that people will go because
the best way to see it is completely you
know cold without any preconceived
notions and I got to see it in Sundance
with an audience which is always
exciting you know doesn't because they
you know if people do a studio screening
everybody's predisposed to really like
it here was you know an audience that
was really honest and then reaction that
was wonderful I wonder if we can
roleplay
actually oh wow a quick roll place okay
and it okay yeah no well okay so I'm
listening tomorrow okay pg-13 we won't
offend anybody but can you practice or
short sort of show me how you pitched
mark the script without giving away and
I know this is the tough part you didn't
have to
yeah well that's a phone call the
Hollywood the thing is like there are
people who are doing all of these things
kind of for you like we wrote a script
and then our producers I imagine got
that in the hands of either your
daughter or your representation probably
my daughter and then you had the chance
to reruns everything I don't know what's
going on we were fortunate in that one
of our producers is friends with Chelsea
so it's that right right that is correct
other news over here oh great choice
oh we could still do the role play okay
let's do it uh here here's the here's
what had been like hey hey Billy over at
Lonely Island can you get this or will
Overlord Miller can you get this script
over to Chelsea Hamel to potentially get
it to Mark Hamill we'll do our best okay
thank you
and I imagine you get a phone call or an
email send me a deal memo I don't care
about the script I just want to know how
much I can make do I get any back-end I
like y'all the money it's believe me at
this point in my career
the script is everything I was saying
Kyle earlier I don't even know how much
I made for this move because once I like
something and then you factor in the
fact that they they don't have a huge
budget that's what I love about this
George called Star Wars the most
expensive low-budget movie ever made
and what George call he's retired now
but I his point was that all the money's
up on the screen the only feel they
really had to pay real money to were
allocated some peter cushing because we
were pretty much all unknowns and with
this you know I was set up in the wrong
way because I thought it's called brings
me bear and it's co-written by Kyle
Mooney and it's directed by the Saturday
Night Live die and Andy samberg's
connected and becbennett and all these
in Mikaela so I was expecting this broad
you know over-the-top comedy and I was
it was so unexpected I loved it from
from the first time I read it did the
character of Ted take any convincing
because I know he's a complicated person
without again giving away too much um
but I think I had read something in the
press notes mark that you said he's the
kind of character that you'd rather
watch rather than play I mean there's
there through the very stars there's a
lot of layers to yeah yeah well again I
mean it wasn't in the standpoint that I
have to play a character that everyone
admires you know I love playing
villainous roles but no villain ever
thinks of themselves as evil they did
the right thing in their estimation but
there's no getting around he did
something that terrifies any parent you
know that's like their worst fear but
again that wasn't so as important in the
largest scheme of things I was just
trying to understand a person that we do
that and I think Jane Addams who plays
my wife does a lot in making you
understand their relationship and how
controlling and aggressive she is but
she brings a lot more to the table than
men's in the script so we were really
lucky to have her go are you aware of
how other people who are fan obsessed
are going to relate to this film because
it shows such a great I mean it's its
own story but it also sort of attribute
to you and all of your good neighbor
sort of YouTube sketch comedy group on
just being obsessed in making something
and just wonder if you could just talk
about
well I'm I'm an obsessive person and
I've had so many obsessions throughout
my life
Star Wars being one of them at one point
and yeah it's true I mean i-i've there
are people who look love our videos and
who followed us for so long and I hope
they come to see this because it's not
it's not necessarily what those videos
are it's it's different but we in terms
of obsession and fandom I don't know we
just what you see on screen is the way a
lot of us feel you know we have such a
strong connection to these TV shows or
movies or music and and it's not always
a terrible thing you know in the case of
this movie like James's love for Briggs
a bear kind of unites him and his
friends and his family and they make
this thing together you never outgrew
you have grow these things right you
said it was a point where I like Star
Wars because basically oh our fans are
the young and the mentally young no my
point
I've never outgrown Star Wars my point
was that there was a specific time where
I was probably the most obsessed about
it now it's turned into a minor
obsession okay just checking
it's okay I mean people come up and say
I'm really sorry I've never seen Star
Wars well that's fine I'm not upset
that's okay it's not for everybody
you know like I say the young and the
mentally on those are the ones that
really are our biggest fans there's
something to be said about it appeals to
the child in all of us because you see
grown men policemen and firemen who are
authority figures let down their guard
and become 9 years old again I proposed
with this lightsaber really you were
just about to arrest me now you're my
friend it's been amazing because I I
never expected it to have this sort of
longevity or the impact on these people
and you meet people all the time until I
became what I became because of that
movie so it's quite it's awesome when
you think about the
that the impact that it's had after all
these years I certainly never thought
I'd be so talking about it and that's
what we're trying to do with bricks
Italy I was 60 there and I think you're
well on your way because it is it's like
a Valentine to obsessive compulsives you
know it's saying it's okay to be this
way you know I love the fact that James
is so accepted by the teenagers because
you think we'll gosh someone that
innocent you know he's almost like Rip
Van Winkle he wakes up in a in a world
he never made and see I love this scene
was the the teenage party they're having
and he doesn't know all the vernacular
he's using some of the slang wrong and
instead of being cynical and ostracizing
him and making fun of him he's accepted
I mean it's charming it really is
you